new york times reporter has sparked
outrage with a tweet claiming
the theory that the coronavirus
originated from a lab in wuhan china
is racist she tweeted thursday
someday we will stop talking about the
lab leak theory and maybe even
admit its racist roots but alas that day
is not yet here that reporter who mainly
covers the coronavirus
then deleted the tweet saying it was
quote
badly phrased senator ted cruz joined
the outcry
with this this is the science reporter
for the new york times
she calls herself an investigative
reporter covering covet 19.
she just isn't willing to investigate or
report on
anything that might hurt her tender
feelings
dr sapphire i come to you
well harris you know so yes the most
plausible theory when you have any local
outbreak
is when you have natural spillover with
animals and humans close together that
happens
um but you cannot deny the coincidences
and the strange occurrences
that went on at the wuhan institute of
virology just
eight miles down the road from this web
market
and it is the mecca coronavirus research
lab of the world
and when you actually started looking at
certain things you know there was
there was a lot of funny things that
went on so just being able to ask those
questions
was very important because lab leaks
happen
this wouldn't be the first time it
happened in fact it happened in china
russia the united states with a lot of
different pathogens so you have to ask
those questions but immediately
because president trump mentioned it
that anti-trumpism
just turned it into something that it
wasn't and anybody who gave any credence
to that theory
was deemed anti-science and wrong
well including you dr sapphire before we
move on i'm going to ask the
the team to pop up what they can in
support of this because
uh vox.com wrote last july that dr
sapphire said she did not believe that
fauci engineered the coronavirus
but she also said that there were
several theories about its origins and
endorsed the theory of covet 19 possibly
being man-made
within a laboratory a theory for which
there is no evidence
um they did take that back they did have
to take it down take it back
dr sapphire well well harris so
the the chronovirus that's been
circulating sarsko v2
that lab had the most genetically
similar coronavirus in it
as to the one circulating today which
has not been found in the wild and we
know based on their published research
that they were genetically modifying
certain coronaviruses
also with similar mutations that are in
sars cov2
now again all of that can happen in
nature certainly can
but you still have to ask those
questions and i had those questions at
the beginning
and because i know history can repeat
itself i know accidental lab leaks can
happen
that's why i said i couldn't say with
certainty that it wasn't from the lab
you know kaylee i i immediately thought
of you as i was
listening to dr king yester excuse me
general keen yesterday talk about there
are 75 labs
in china that the united states knows
about some of them
weaponize certain biotechnology
uh they're practicing at that and he
said
that this lab in wuhan was one of them
it was not clear if this was one of the
viruses that they were trying to do that
with but that they do that at that lab
yeah you're exactly right and look i i
want to say this and i will get to that
point here
the press's role in this now that we
know that this is a credible theory
we've known it since the president of
united states former president of the
united states donald trump
told us this last year the press of
course called him a conspiracy theorist
and now even in the wake of this finding
by the wall street journal and the
intelligence community that people were
sick at the lab
even in the wake of that some reporters
can't bring themselves
to admit the credibility of that theory
like jonathan lemire who's in the white
house press corps
who said president trump's engaging in
revisionist history
by saying he was citing the lab as the
origin
it's not revisionist history it's called
the truth and maggie haberman
said it's president trump's fault we
didn't believe him because he never
showed us evidence
but to the point you just made mike
pompeo came out on january 15th and said
here's the evidence and he laid out
three points about the wuhan lab gate
engaging in gain of function research
and the sick members at that laboratory
and exactly as you just said that this
institute
has had ties uh to working on military
projects with the chinese government so
there was evidence
the reporters just chose to ignore it
well
and i want to get to more of what was
going on with the media and david
i'll come to you on this cbs reporter
nancy cordes yesterday made this
concession about the development
surrounding the wuhan lab leak
theory watch it's a vindication of sorts
for
trump-era officials who long argue they
believe that this
virus originated in a lab only to be
dismissed in part
because of some of their anti-china
rhetoric
and you say what it has to first be
noted
that you have been on this since day one
harris in trying to get to the
bottom of it and find answers the
question for our country and the media
may want to start
asking president biden is what steps is
he willing to take
if it is discovered that this was
intentionally done
by china are we going to throw them out
of the stock market are we going to quit
taking investment from them
are we going to are we gonna seek to
sabotage their bio
biological research what steps is
president biden willing to take
if china did this intentionally and
caused a world pandemic
well maybe we have an idea kennedy
because yesterday and thank you for
acknowledging that
my twitter feed looked like a sticker
box because
the government was posting stickers why
is she asking this question just stick a
cdc sticker on it and whatever
and dr siegel with our team said just
keep asking your questions harris don't
back down
um so so kennedy when you look at where
we have come
in the information there were certain
things that we really did know
enough about to ask questions and when
you shut down the media from asking
questions you do so in danger of the
public
i wonder if we could have asked the
questions even before
we really knew what we were dealing with
about china
but words like xenophobic would pop up
even though they were fact-based
evidence-based type questions
so what did dr fauci know about this
gain of function research
and what did he know about weaponizing
certain viruses with the communist
chinese military
particularly in that lab there there was
a lot more that had been gleaned by
intelligence the cdc the nih
and dr fauci's institute and they were
not
forthcoming and they were they were very
adamant that this
was animal to human transmission and if
that is not the case uh not only does
china have to be held accountable
and i talked about this last night on my
fox business show we should not as an
international community be granting them
the olympics
because they have said china has said
they are not going to participate in
further investigation
with the world health organization that
they're done they've done enough
they have not done enough because all of
these questions remain
so what are we going to do to really
punish them to make sure this doesn't
happen again
to kaylie's point we don't know what
else is in those other labs
and that should terrify people you know
because this was
in terms of the viruses that are studied
that are
you know juiced up in rand paul's
language
this is pretty mild so i don't want to
see the moderate or the severe viruses
escape those labs in the future and also
in the united states
i want to know what people like dr fauci
knew and when did they know it
and when did they feel it was okay to
lie to us and let
hundreds of thousands of people die in
this country
well and look kennedy we got a little
tip of what the president would do
yesterday and david to your point too
um it was breaking news during this hour
that the president was talking about
this topic
ask about it and whether or not he would
release the 90-day review
once they take a look at the origins as
best they can
because as you know we pointed out on
the panel china's not exactly saying
come on in
um and he said well yeah he'll release
that
unless there's something in it that he
was unaware of so then my question would
be david
what do you already know that you're not
telling us last word
it's a great question and that's why
secretary pompeo wanted to investigate
it and others have wanted to investigate
it and finally we're going to get an
investigation and maybe
americans will get some answers more
importantly though
all the more reason why medical supplies
and prescription medicines need to be
made here in the united states
the evidence is gone at this point like
i hate to break it to people but i mean
it's not there anymore yeah
decoupling from china particularly on
pharmaceuticals and then
vacuuming up potentially all of the ppe
as we were all trying to get it too
because
they already knew that it was coming dr
sapphire you've written a book
called panic attack and we're going to
talk about it a little bit later this
hour because
you really delved in to some of the
issues that americans have questions
about from the very very beginning
and thank you for all of your questions
from the beginning because uh
without us doing those things who know
who knows where we would be